that's a great idea I'm glad I brought
this up I should do this I love how you
were like you gave me a great idea but
the thing you said was completely
different than what I said that's how
that's how this works that's how this
thing
works that's a little yes and there for
you to all my thespians out
[Music]
there all right we're live Sean what are
we what are we talking about you're
kicking it off well maybe you should
introduce yourself I don't even
recognize you because it's New Year New
You am I right
Sam save me new
year new year same [__] as always yeah
nothing nothing will change I I have I
didn't I purposely didn't set any goals
this year I'm just gonna go with the
flow what why what are you what are you
thinking well I want to talk about New
Year's um resolutions and stuff at first
I have to apologize we did not put out a
lot of content over the last week or so
normally who cares no big deal and I
thought well you know this is good let's
take a little break spend time with the
family you're a new dad I'm an existing
Dad let's just be quality home home
bodies here and F family men family
first right but the thing is about
family first is that the time I need
podcast the most is when I'm with my
family this might sound crazy to people
who aren't podcast people but I know
there's other people like me out there
who you love your family you spend a lot
of time with your family a little too
much time sometimes with your family and
you need this little mini breaks um I
was taking out the trash and I was then
I had to like walk my dog and I was like
I went to my favorite podcasters Channel
and they didn't have anything new for me
and I was like damn this is what I
needed I needed a little break from the
family world just to go and Escape who's
your favorite podcaster um I like Bill
Simmons he's it's because I like to just
listen to basketball stuff or or Sports
things and so I will and I've been
listening to him since I don't know 2006
or something he's like the first
podcaster I've ever heard um so I have
this familiarity built up and when
there's not a new episode I hate it and
I
realized we're that person for some
people out there we are there we are
there uh escape from family card or
escape from the boring you know
chore and I know that it was holiday
time but I bet people needed us more and
we weren't there so next year we will be
there that's my commitment to you guy
out there who's who's has to run errands
and deal with a bunch of BS we should
have just done reruns could we have done
a rerun and it been all right just our
voices actually just ASMR of us saying
nonsense just gibberish for hours um did
you have you ever seen this Louis CK
skit or like or one of his bits from his
standup thing where he talks about being
a dad now that now now that you're a dad
you're going to start to appreciate this
one joke it's not even that
funny you know some people are like it's
so true that's that's hilarious this is
just it's so true it's not even that
hilarious what he say he talks about
he's like um the greatest 30 seconds in
the world he's like you know what the
greatest 30 seconds in the world is he's
like when you put your kid in the car
and you [__] you get him into the car
seat you finally clip it all together
and then you close the door and you have
like 30 seconds while you're walking
from their door back to your door and
that 30 seconds of silence and Solitude
is everything in life and it's so true
this was the the first week that I
experienced where I was like oh a break
would be nice because my my baby has
been perfect mostly but like she goes to
like a week of growing and she'll cry
more than normal mostly she doesn't cry
at all and I remember there was a day
where she cried for like an hour and I
was like all right I understand why why
why people request breaks because before
I was like why would I ever want to
leave this thing I'm getting so much
dopamine from it now it was the first
time that I experienced a break so I'm
slowly understanding some of these
things um do you know how chill I am
when my like our Nanny will be like Oh
I'm sick or whatever she calls out sick
or you hey my my daughter's visiting
from college can I have the day off and
dude I get I'm in my head I'm like yeah
of course no problem but in my soul I'm
like enraged I'm like how dare you make
me spend all day with my kids how dare
you how I have to look after my own like
you know this is an injustice that has
happened to me that don't you feel guilt
you don't feel guilt you're like the
guilt being why am I so reliant on this
person I experienced that a little bit
cuz we have a Night Nurse I'm past that
I fully accepted that that is the way I
need to live and that that is a
necessity and actually a right of mine a
core a core human right an American
right of Mine by the way right up there
next with aoli being just flavored
mayonnaise Night Nurse is beautiful
rebranding it's basically just this
young woman who I have no idea what her
credentials really are but she just like
plays on her phone While She lays on the
couch next to my daughter and when she
cries at this point now it's only one
night a week or one time a night and she
gives her a bottle and then just goes
back to sleep and I'm basically paying
someone a full-time salary to live and
sleep on my couch right and because we
call it a nurse I think there's some
type of medical compon it ain't there if
it was called uh if it was called like
sleep sitter and it's a babysitter we
just pay her you know to help with one
one one moment while we sleep it' feel a
little different than night
yes beautiful rebranding by the way I
think the the aoli for this is got to be
opare by the way what a word what a
fantastic word okay we can move on yeah
opair is a beautiful one too by the way
do we're thinking about getting an opair
and uh I was like wait so we just get
this like young 23y old who's just going
to be living at our home and it's kind
of weird it's it's pretty weird when do
you think about it it's weird right okay
so now I want to talk about resolutions
so in the past do you do resolution you
said you didn't do it this year is that
part of like chill mod yeah so so so
what I do is I have four categories and
I named them all FS because it's cute so
Family Fitness Fun finances so I'll
usually have a finance goal of like I
want to make this much money I want to
launch this thing do this that's a
business thing friendship would be the
last one and I was so excited for myself
there but okay finances works too that
that's fun that's fun the Forgotten
fifth F okay that's fun so fun is like
trips I want to do this with friends
whatever family is uh you know Sarah and
I want to achieve this thing together we
want to communicate more I don't know
whatever it is and then uh Fitness is
you know this much weight lifted this
whatever normally I do that right now
I've not said it and I'm said I'm going
to do quarterly but I'm not gonna start
it for another month yeah oh dude I'm in
this I'm on the I'm in the same boat I
have a very very similar exercise that I
do I think mine are like you know work
play uh love and you know whatever
Fitness or health you know something
like that branding is is a lot better
you should do Family Fitness Finance fun
well I just don't want to use your thing
now cuz feel like oh I'm going to do
Sam's New Year resolutions
today kill me now all right so um so so
I agree with what you normally do and I
normally do the same but I don't know
why I had extreme aversion to it this
year and so I looked up some
alternatives to New Year's resolutions
the aversion I think came from
a bunch of thread Boys on Twitter I
think honestly there's just like a lot
of content on Twitter right now of
people being like just wrapped up the
annual plan annual review of 2023 and my
predictions and plans for 2024 and I was
like just just too much for me I can't I
need to just get away from this and no
one hits them and in general I would say
if I try to think of all right what is
what is the new stuff I'm going to do
it's such a small boy attitude to be
like yeah I waited till the uh I waited
till the first to do the things I wanted
to do it's like no I like anything I
wanted to do anything I realized I
should do a decision I just made in in
that moment and started doing it
immediately I just did it on November
21st instead of January 1 and so I think
what are your Alternatives okay so a
couple Alternatives you tell me if you
like these or not so saw this on Tik Tok
this is definitely such a a sort of
jenzy approach to life they go New Year
resolutions goals uh are what are you my
dad bingo card New Year's bingo card so
here's here's how a New Year's bingo
card works I I don't know how many
things are on a bingo grid I think it's
like 16 squares so you just come up with
16 but also leave a couple blank if you
can't think of them gen Z that's how we
roll um you just come up with some
things that you might do this year it's
a maybe it's a huh huh might go might go
to travel might go backpacking through
Central America might not though
um might start dating somebody also fine
alone and that's blank you just come you
know you come up with squares of things
that might be fun to do this year got it
and then you just see if you do them and
if you do them Bingo you just try to you
shade it in you you shade in the square
and you see how you get a bigo card and
it's a low pressure Vis but it's like an
actual little vision board and I was
like I think I kind of like this by the
way on my bingo card this year if I were
to do it I they're in Houston they're
doing a zerg flight and it's five grand
and they take you up into this have you
seen that they take you up into like a
747 that's like empty and it's like full
of like pillows and you float for like
20 seconds at a time that's going to be
on my bingo card this year I'm I'm
scared of it but I so I might do it
might do it what an attitude what a what
a new attit what a refreshing attitude
to the new year right so the jenz Bingo
cart this data is wrong every freaking
time have you heard heard of
HubSpot HubSpot is a CRM platform where
everything is fully integrated W I can
see the client's whole history call
support tickets emails and here's a task
from 3 days ago I totally
missed HubSpot grow
better here's another one this is comes
from the uh the psychology World here
are my New Year's
anticipations what what is that you just
say things you're looking forward to
this year you just brainstorm you just
say oh man I'm looking forward to that
that would be so fun that would be
amazing and the reason why is these
psychologists did a study and they found
that actually more joy is derived from
the anticipation of an event from versus
the actual event itself and like I just
had this with my kids for Christmas like
we did the Elf on the Shelf thing um and
just in general like the build the whole
buildup to Christmas Day and the idea of
Christmas morning and opening up all
your presents like
I got 25 days of joy out of that from
them because the anticipation and then
on the day of you know they woke up they
started ripping presents open they
didn't even know which one to play which
toy to play with and uh it was over like
an hour and then they were like okay can
we have cartoons with breakfast now and
I was like yep all right I guess back to
the routine and uh and it was kind of
done and I just realized these people
are right New Year's anticipations might
be a thing because instead of planning
and committing like some some brute
Alpha saying I'm gonna do this you just
say oh I can't wait to have x and x x
experience I can't wait to do why and uh
that that might be a little bit more
more fulfilling what do you think eight
all right eight I give that an eight
that's pretty good wow okay I thought
you were pretty on bingo card bingo card
is cool and I you know anytime you said
if you say I read a study that said this
it's like saying that's like when a
restaurant has a sign that says world's
greatest cup of coffee I have a rule
that if I see a restaurant that says
world's greatest blank I always go to it
that's my rule because I think if you
have the audacity to say that then I
will give you the I'll try it so that
that if you say yeah so like uh hearing
someone say a study once said just makes
me weak in the knees and gets me all hot
and bothered so I'm you know the funny
thing by the way so I saw that and I was
like you didn't see a study on it that
that's no so I was like who oh I was
like for the first time ever I was like
yeah I'll take the special right like
you know the waiter read specials you
never ordered the special I was like let
me read the study and I scrolled down
and it said University of Scranton and I
was like oh pretty sure it's a madeup
town from the office I don't think
Scranton exists and so oh oh Dunder
Mifflin came out with a study this year
so this is probably [__] but uh
nevertheless that's that's where the
study came from all right here's another
one there's this guy on uh on Twitter
that's he's made his brand all around
the idea of obsession you know this guy
no I wish what what's what is
it yeah basically it's like the good
version of OCD he's like uh anyway he's
all about being obsessed and so he goes
he goes my he instead of New Year's
resolution he goes my year of obsession
he goes I believe that a one-year
Obsession can change your life that's
awesome that's an awesome sentence right
that's like a actually a pretty powerful
sentence I read it I was like I'm in and
I closed the tab I was like I don't even
want to anything else you say is gonna
make me like you less than that first
sentence Morgan hle had the guy we had
on he had this great quote he said
people don't remember books they
remember sentences and I try to make
like memorable sentences that's a
memorable sense that's a beautiful sense
and I think that that is so true that
one one year of obsession really can
change your life if you de said this
year I'm going to be obsessed with X and
you just started to just rev up that
engine of obsession and whether it's
around you know working out or it's
around um having fun or it's around you
know this company that you're going to
start or whatever it is creating content
whatever it is I think that's just an
amazing attitude it's for some reason
it's different than a resolution that's
the best I would even say the year of
like identity where you I mean obsession
is actually better but it's like a year
where you change your identity I
remember like do you remember like three
or four years ago when I was kind of
pudgy and I was like this is the year I
become a fitness influencer and I was
joking but I was like I was g i I was I
was gonna make Fitness part of my my
identity right it's the same thing
Obsession identity that's a that's
beautiful that's a beautiful sentence
that's a nine that's a nine okay you're
in on that one um so okay another one
forget forget looking
forward do a New Year's reflection so in
just forget the to the the kind of to-do
list of here's a bunch of promises I'm
going to break to myself you know like
uh which is what the New Year
resolutions tend to be instead just
triple down on the reflection so really
take a walk down memory lane open up
your camera go through your camera roll
go watch you know January February March
April write down what's some of your
your best experiences were you know just
do a little bit of a journal entry kind
of to end the year um send a few thank
you notes uh to people or moments or um
you know people who or or you know
experiences that you had with people
just talking about how great they were
or you know how much you appreciated
having them um reflect on you know maybe
everybody I think everybody always says
um oh man I learned so much and I grew
so much and then if you ever say awesome
what what' you
learn
the writer's block occurs sudden
suddenly silence silence sweeps over the
room um try to actually sus out like
what did I really learn um and what were
the big learning moments for me this
year this happened and my learning was X
and I did like a monster reflection
exercise the other day so fun and I
think that people should do this in a
more intense way forget like the method
just just do it in a more intense way
just be like I'm gonna actually really
try to dig in so I've been doing that
every year for a while and I would just
put them in Google Docs but now so like
if you're listen you're listen I don't
know what day this will go live but if
you go to the anti mba.com you'll see my
reflection and the antiba that's just my
personal blog I barely ever share I
don't give a [__] who reads it um not
that many people read it because I don't
really share it but I started doing this
publicly now just to reflect and my
family will be able to read it in 10 or
30 years which is awesome right imagine
when your mom was coming to India if or
coming from India if she instead of just
telling you the stor she you could read
her blog what she thought then and so
I've been doing that a lot lately um
it's awesome it's really fun and it's
awesome to go through your camera role
because your camera tells you exactly
every month what's going on relationship
hack learned this from Tony Robbins he's
he basically said once a month he's like
me and my he's like it's very easy with
your wife to like uh or your partner and
just to to kind of like get into some
routine where you're just like mostly
your focus and energy is in your work or
your kids or your whatever and like that
kind of dating time is gone and people
try to do they try to like you know
reignite the spark with like oh it's
date night tonight but like you're both
kind of tired and you know you already
have had a bunch of conversations not
that much new stuff to share it's like
hey what's new with you I don't know the
same things you've been going through
you know like we've been together my
in-laws were in town and they were like
hey Sam Sarah do you guys want us to
watch a baby and you could have a date
night and we're like yeah but could our
date night be we're just going to go
upstairs and scroll on our phone
yeah
that sounds great Sam's gonna turn on a
bath and Sarah's gonna leave the house
yeah like that that was our version of
date night so well I have that all the
time that in that case but but Tony
Robin said this he does exercise called
flooding which is he's like real
romantic he's like just sit down and
basically um open up the you know the
camera roll or videos and just watch
together um you know something from like
a year ago three years ago whatever it
is and just kind of flood those memories
um to together and it will almost rebond
you because you'll both you'll both
re-experience what you've already
experienced and um it's a kind of
like low low bar way to uh it's sort of
like the minimum dose you need to get
like sort of a Maximum Impact in terms
of how close you feel with somebody and
I've been doing that it's it's pretty
awesome don't do it every month but like
I do it from time time you should blog
this just play create like a Blog that
no one that you don't care if anyone
reads and and kind of forc yourself to
write on there it's pretty awesome but
dude whenever I write something
everybody reads it it gets like super
popular just don't share it it's just
it's just like uh you know like I you
know my big thing is I read a lot of
history it's crazy people used to like
journal and diary remember when you were
a kid and someone told me about like
having a diary and I'm like dude that's
what like chicks do I'm not going to
write a diary now we're just going to re
brand it call it blogging and it's way
more fun you know do I have it here it's
in the other room right now but uh I
bought not like a journal because you
know most journals are like very small
and uh that's great but like actually
writing in a journal can be kind of uh
it's kind of hard it's kind of limited I
bought one of those artist sketch pads
like a huge like thick card stock canvas
thing this thing is amazing it's a
absolute pleasure to write on and draw
on I don't feel Limited in any way um
way better than a journal I I really
love this thing I leave it on my desk
most days and I just have it there I
could take notes on one side I can
scribble an idea on the other and it's
just the idea of a sketch pad is just
way better than these like yeah but in
20 years your kids are going to be like
why did Dad just make these stupid s's
with the six lines like what is what is
that what is that uh doodle he keeps
that dumb s that everyone
does like why does it keep drawing cubes
like over and over again dude there's no
chance my kids care about what I was
thinking when I was 35 years old or
that's the reality maybe maybe one day
one little thing but uh no all right
last uh last one here for New Year's so
we got the bingo card we got
anticipations we got the obsession we
got the reflection um the last one is
just this one's actually not it's kind
of the best one to end on but the magic
word and the magic word is um you pick a
theme for really just the month so you
forget the year Year's too long you just
say all right January my word word of
the month right now the theme of this
month is going to be
um uh playful flirting I'm flirt with
everybody right you just come up with
whatever the word is I'm going to take
every situation I'm going to try to
infuse this word into it or as as often
as I can I'm gonna try to have this be
the theme right I actually think that's
great what yours gonna be just like
pizza that's
what Ranch
is what doesn't get better with ranch
ranch that's so
funny yeah I think January is just carbs
uh no I think magic is good well no
matter which one of these new years you
pick uh just remember January 12th
January 12th is National quitters day
it's the second Friday after the New
Year by that time I think like more than
half of people have completely abandoned
their thing I saw the guy who the
founder of that that company sliced
pizza they're like a yeah a nationwide
like pizza delivery thing he's like uh
he he said something like January 12th
201 15th he's like
um he's like hey sales will be down for
the next two weeks but then our biggest
day of the year is coming he's like Is
that real super super bowl of pizza
delivery is on National quitters Day
when people give up on their uh on their
diets by the second week of January and
they move on so yeah that that is what
it is second Friday of Jan that company
by the way is killing it who would have
thought who not I not I is the answer
not I not I um all right let me bring up
a juicy topic I got a big juicy one I
got one that when I was researching this
I kept giggling and I kept laughing as a
bystander this topic it it is it is
awesome it has made me so happy and let
me explain why so I've got this friend I
met him in Hampton I think he said that
you knew him through one of his software
companies uh he won some contest we did
his name is Spencer Scott and he owns
two software companies the software
company that I think he spoke to us
about it's pretty funny you go to like
your website so for in our case let's
say mfmp pod.com and you could see who's
on your website and you could video call
with them and it just pops up and it
says hey you in Austin if you have any
questions I'm here in real time you can
ask me questions whatever he's got these
software companies I think they probably
do4 or $500,000 a year in Revenue he
makes a great Living Well something
happened to him and the way that he
reacted to this is just hilarious so
Spencer lives outside of Dallas and
apparently there is an issue where the
trash collectors come and they leave
their trash bins like they come and pick
up the bins and they leave them like all
over the place and so seeing that he's
like a scrappy
entrepreneur I'm looking at a photo of
that like we should post a photo of this
on the YouTube channel there's
somebody's uh trash cans like one looks
like it got in a World Star Hip-Hop
fight it just got beat up it's on the
ground another one is just at the
neighbor's lawn and then one is where
it's supposed to be and he's like this
is how they left my trash again today
and it makes and it made the neighbors
really angry apparently people he had
heard like people complain about this
and so the the group I guess it's uh is
it called Wy Texas page Wy Texas yeah it
says like what whatever his neighborhood
is like residence and then it's in in
the little town that he's in and he
explains this like in a really funny way
he goes we've got my my NE my
neighborhood is supposed to be one of
these fancy neighborhood gated uh it's a
gated community we've got 24-hour
security hell we even have 48 48 hour
security if you take into account all
the car that live in my neighborhood and
Report stuff like we're just full of
security and yet our trash it's just so
annoying that once a week the the
company picks it up and our cans are
left all over the place so he makes a
Facebook post in the neighborhood group
and he says Hey neighbors is anyone open
to switching trash services to a better
option my wife and I are mildly
frustrated with cards and we've made
jokes that we feel we are like unpaid
employees every week we play a fun game
of where's Waldo trying to find our
trash cans which are either in the ditch
or hidden in our neighbors yards
whatever and then uh 150 people
commented on that and so this guy uh
Spencer Scott he calls himself he's like
a Jehovah's Witness of B2B sales
apparently before he started a software
company he would go door too selling
internet services or uh uh I think phone
lines things like that so he's just like
a like a door to door sales guy then he
got into software and he's a pretty
Scrappy guy and he goes hell I think I'm
going to do this he finds out that the
trash company is actually charging
something like 50 bucks a month for 300
houses he does some math he goes this is
kind of interesting and so he starts
sending an email or uh so he makes a new
Post in the Facebook group and listen to
this he goes in order for this to work
we need 200 houses to sign up and commit
to switching vendors I and this is a
great post by the way I know this is a
huge ass and you're gonna you're going
to be taking on a risk on a new startup
but I can assure you we are going to be
Lighty years better than cards and this
is the good part if we aren't I'm sure
they'll take us back I've got everything
lined up including two advisers who have
been in the industry for years what do
you say you want to help us start start
a trash company with me and so he
creates this website where he just
Googled like referral programs and I
linked to the website where Tim Ferris
he actually made a blog post where he
talked about Harry's their their
pre-launch uh strategy and so he made
this account if you go to his website
his website is uh uh is it lonar
trash.com Great Name by the way it's
hilarious this website and so if you
refer a new customer you get a T-shirt
If you refer 10 customers you get uh one
free month of trash pickup and So within
like 24 48 Hours he sets up a stripe uh
uh a stripe account he collects
$155,000 in sales and so with that
$155,000 he says [__] I'm in business he
goes out and he buys 200 trash bins
because that's I guess how many
customers he got for month one and
there's a picture of all these trash
bins in his
driveway then he goes on Facebook
Marketplace searches like within 500
miles and he finds a trash like a trash
garbage truck for sale for 40 Grand
apparently AMX I didn't know they allow
this but they give you a line of credit
up to 60 or 80 grand for 7% interest he
uses that and he buys this truck without
ever seeing it so he calls the guy and
he's like hey do a FaceTime with me
whatever spends two grand gets this
truck shipped to his house now he's in
business and tomorrow is his first day
in business and he's got two tomorrow
he's got to get up at 4:00 a.m. it's one
day a week it's one with I'm gonna go
with them not tomorrow but over the next
uh few weeks we're gonna I'm gonna get a
video career I think we gotta go do this
but this guy has started a uh trash can
or trash business and so in so let me
see I have his math here he was like I
think a bad year is going to be about
150 Grand in Revenue I think a decent
year will be 250 and I think a great
year will be 3 50 and if it works well
I'll expand to new regions and it's
crazy fascinating that he's doing this
and he's doing it mostly in public where
he's like tweeting out all the stuff
that he's doing and it's just so funny
that this guy's doing this because he's
like making a joke about it so for
example he bought hoodies for himself
and I guess the one employee he has and
thises what's the T-shirt say it says
says it says great days start with a
good dump picture of his garbage truck
and I had him like interview for uh to
get information for this pot I asked him
all these questions and I wrote him down
and he's taking a very technical like
techy analysis towards us he's like look
at the search uh the SEO for the largest
company Waste Management they have this
many pages but the second uh highest in
the country only has 650 pages I think I
could rank there by doing X Y and Z and
it's crazy fascinating and get this so
one truck holds I got to remember this
one truck holds 200 bins worth of trash
and those 200 bins worth of trash cost
$250 to dump so the costs are going to
be the the truck the cans which
eventually pay off pretty quickly and
then labor so it's a pretty fascinating
business and I cannot believe that he
just went all in on this and he's making
it happen I appreciate people who do
this so much I love this story and I
feel very invested in this I've invested
in a lot of companies but I feel
invested in this I need this to work
lonar trash I feel like we should
single-handedly pump this and to all
listeners in the uh where is he Dallas
he's uh 30 minutes outside of Dallas and
he explicitly said he goes when you talk
about this pod on the Pod I'm afraid
that too many people are going to go to
my website and there's a buy now button
and I'm just going to have to like go
through all the work of refunding them
and telling them we can't service them
so I have to remind people he is only
servicing one region right he's like he
says my neighborhood has um
I think three 400 houses and then
there's 400 houses in the S sister
neighborhood he says the trash
collecting company is currently charging
$33 per month per bin so most houses
have two bins so it's 66 bucks a month
so let's just do the math here 66 bucks
a month just his neighborhood that's 26k
a month 316,000 a year double it for for
both and that's like sort of 600 Grand
of potential Revenue if he got everybody
to switch of course not going to get
everybody to switch but I do think he
could do pretty well so here's should we
brainstorm a few marketing tactics for
him but it's actually could be
potentially bigger than than we think so
he goes he goes I he goes I talked he
goes basically I went and T went on
Facebook Marketplace and I found all
these trash guys uh who were selling
these trucks and I just played dumb with
them I was like he's like I didn't even
play dumb I am dumb I don't know
anything about this and so he makes
friends with all these guys on Facebook
Marketplace who are selling trucks and
he's like I fly up there and I meet one
of them and he's like this guy is in
Oklahoma you would think that he's just
a country bumpkin his business did 9
million in Revenue 2 million in it he
owns a plane that he flies around in and
he starts talking to these guys and he
learns that there's a small town mcken
which is north of Dallas I guess it's a
small City uh they it just went out to
bid for them to get a new trash
collector it was 50,000 houses and the
contract is $20 million a year and
that's a a relatively small region
outside of Dallas so it potentially
could be bigger and we know uh we talked
about Wayne hinga a billionaire who
started um AutoNation Blockbuster and
waste management now he used to own the
Florida Panthers and then we talked
about Bradley Jak jaob who's a
multi-billionaire who started also with
trash businesses maybe it could be
bigger than we think well Spencer if
you're listening to this which I I'd be
stunned if you didn't listen to this
giant segment about your
company me and Sam we haven't talked
about this I don't know if Sam's cool
with this but we're gonna buy your next
truck for you sir we are gonna invest in
your company and we will fund your next
truck and that will be the MFM trash
truck how many other podcasts do you
know that will have their own trash dude
I would 100 I would I would I would put
up 20 grand to we're both in for 20
grand we'll buy the next 40K truck
whenever he's ready to to expand this
we'll come in at a low valuation here
right give us a you know $500,000
valuation and uh we as this podcast will
then single-handedly promote this
neighborhood by neighborhood as you
expand but I think you should do a
couple things so here's a few free
marketing ideas for him do you know can
you design the the bins like could he
paint the bins could he color the bins
in a different way or or design them so
that if you're using this trash company
your bins will look different I don't
see why not I mean like a bright pink
one or something like the lift mustache
back in the day remember when when you
would go through San Francisco you'd see
these cars driving with this fluffy
mustache on it like what the heck is
that and then somebody would have to
tell you right it it was so weird you
had to ask what is that and then as soon
as somebody knew they were happy to tell
you oh that's lift it's a ride sharing
company you could actually just request
a ride on your phone and then the driver
will show up like that that's his car he
puts the mustache on it that means he's
attacking you and it's like whoa okay
interesting and the lift I have a lift
mustache right
here I admired this marketing tactic so
much I stole a mustache off a car and I
have this thing so you'll have to have
like um he could have like he could
paint like cookies on on the bin and
then the truck will look like Cookie
Monster or something where it's like
silly when it like goes intock the truck
and the the bins need to become his
marketing assets and so the bins should
look like you've made a choice that you
have decided to go with the local
provider who's all about service that's
has fun blah blah blah right so make the
bins fun and interesting in some way
great idea First Step um Second Step he
should go around and basically fly after
that other company puts bins out and uh
you know let's say they're knocked over
or in the wrong spot he should put a
little thing that says we would never do
this to you uh we're a new company
started by a guy who lives here I was so
frustrated and Del your little founder
story put it as a Slip inside of every
trash bin um because you're you're
really just Marketing in this 400 house
radius right so pretty easy next thing I
don't know if you know this Sam kids
love garbage trucks garbage trucks fire
trucks they just love them so take the
truck on tour like the Wiener mobile do
you remember that the Oscar meire Wier
mobile ex go to school exactly this is
the Oscar Meer play Playbook and so in
our town uh the fire department for
Christmas they always like they'll bring
the fire truck out they'll like play
music off it they'll put a Santa on top
do the same thing every holiday you're
putting the your your truck's going to
drive around it's going to be themed and
it's GNA like you know create an
occasion for the F like when when a
garbage truck comes outside here I grab
my kids and we run outside because they
love to see it they love to see it pick
up the trash whatever and so use do
something that's going to get the kids
to do it so for example uh go around let
the kids ride in the truck or or drive
the truck or something like that uh or
let everybody get out their hose and
wash the truck so you can like spray
your hose at the truck while it's going
by create something that's going to get
kids excited to see it and families
excited to see it so that they know who
you are tell your story um so I think if
he does this he could literally get like
80% of the neighborhood on board because
the other trash company does no
marketing whatsoever and it sounds like
they're not doing a great job there's a
little bit of an opening here to uh to
go in and and sell a better service I
think it's just fast fascinating I think
that like obviously the margins are
going to be way worse than software but
you have a recurring element here um
every I mean the the size of the market
is every home in America uh and also
like just what he's doing like you
remember how we talked about pinks pinks
was a window cleaning company Y and for
some reason they just have cool hats and
people have their hats they sent they
sent me one I wear it it's awesome the
like what he's doing with great days
start with a good dump like that little
silly stuff or like the fact that his
website is kind of funny and how it has
a a affiliate
program this is brilliant I do think
he's missing that branding though in the
the there's no like uh like you know
pinks is is got its its color it's got
its name it's got whatever uh there's
like the two guys in a truck kind of
like moving company that's another good
one where it's like you know two two
dudes in a truck he needs something like
that yeah but uh keep it mind I'm pretty
sure he started this three weeks ago uh
so he's like he's like look why does
everything figured out yeah I decided
this was my mission eight weeks ago I'm
all in like just you know you can't stop
me now also we'll crowdsource this dude
if there's a design agency that listens
to the Pod you need to do a free a pro
bono free full branding you know where's
Red antler red antler I need you to do
take on this project for free in
exchange for marketing collateral that
you did this truck this uh this trash
company uh this local trash company in
Texas branding we need a design company
to let's crowdsource all everything we
need to make this happen and he said uh
so I had him fill this out on 12:15 he
goes I came up with this idea 60 days
ago so what's that that's uh so uh in
October 15th he came up with the idea uh
and then he got customers that fast I I
just can't believe this it's just so
funny and he's got all these pictures of
all these bins in front of his house of
him and his wife cleaning the bins uh
it's it's just this is Art also Tik Tock
he needs to go on Tik Tok and tell the
story I don't know if you've seen But
like
uh so somebody posted this Tik Tok the
other day they go oh you're worried
about um oh like you know you want to
start posting on Tik Tok but you're
worried what do I have to say or how do
I look or whatever and the woman goes do
you know what I watch on this app I
watch I watch guys cut sand I watch
women clean houses I watch and it's like
I watch a massage therapist I don't even
get the massage I watch other people get
massages dude I watch chiropractors and
fruit getting crushed yeah cracking
necks and opening up avocados like
what are you waiting for and I think
that is a a uh you know Mark andreon did
it's time to build as this rally
cry there's like the equivalent one of
like do you know what I watch I'll watch
anything is the rally Cry of Tik Tok and
I think he's got to tell the story of
like this Dad this father of two who got
so annoyed with his trash company that
he's just decided like all right eff it
I'm doing this he says that he goes his
goal is uh 24 customers in less than 18
months which is around a thou a million
dollars in ARR uh he said he's going to
hit a thousand C customers in the first
six months and his first day driving the
truck he's he goes I screwed around with
it a little bit to test it out uh but I
really like am just getting going
tomorrow for the first time and then
listen to this listen to this guy's
humor he goes I go are you looking to
hire for certain positions he goes yeah
in fact as I as I'm typing this I'm
sitting at the bar at DAV Busters
watching adults play the claw game
anyone who wins I slipped in my biz card
and give them an invite to make $20 an
hour driving my trash trucks uh this
guy he's great man he's great he's great
he's he's full of humor this is awesome
this is a really cool thing that he
started as just like a stupid idea but
it's got legs and I think that this is
gonna be awesome this can make because I
think Spencer also wants a bit of uh a
bit of Fame a little bit of content Fame
yeah yeah yeah not just that I think he
you know from meeting him I think he has
an urge that I have a very Primal urge
inside which is like I just want to live
like I just want to do something
different with my life you know like I
just want to do something different than
the like path like okay I get it I could
do the path but I really don't want to
just do the path I think Spencer has
this which is what leads somebody to do
something like this and I my it sounds
like he's already pretty all in but
triple down go even further all in
Rebrand yourself as trash Daddy tell
your story to the world like do the
unnecessary like you know every Sunday
have a theme uh you know like remember
how Goan used to do this with sprig he
used to put a truffle in every box like
you know every time you ordered you get
a little chocolate truffle with it like
just keep coming up with surprise and
Delight ways to go do the absolute
unnecessary because that's what people
pay attention to the things yeah like
leaving a toy trash truck in people's
mailbox or something like that ex Sam
brilliant
I should be doing this frankly this is
this is my type of get out of the
way yeah yeah he's the ride Graves I'm
the Travis kinic I need to take this
thing over uh this needs to be my
business his ass
on no I think this is awesome so I
what's his handle his just if you look
up Spencer Scott I think his handle is
AKA Spencer Scott um on Twitter this is
going to be a really fun Journey for us
to follow along and we're early in the
we're early on this and we're going to
help make this a thing this is Awesome
by the way Spencer if you're listening
holler at us I I know I talked to you
about this before but now it's public
record yeah that was awesome okay wow
what a segment what a way to start off
the new year that was that was amazing
that's what this podcast is all about if
this is your first time listening to
this podcast that's what this podcast is
all about yeah finding cool stuff all
right I wanted to tell you another just
like fun product real quick this is a
quick one click this link to this thing
birdie birdie. design
is the name of it dude I can't tell if
these things are popular like is this
like a Yellow Cab where like I noticed
one and they're everywhere or they have
they always been everywhere we talked
about this type of stuff a while ago uh
it's everywhere now I've I've never seen
one you've seen one of these in real
life no well go ahead and explain what
it is okay so I'll explain it into the
cont into context of this one of the
running jokes on the Pod is that a
completely valid business model is just
X
beautifully done and if you're pitching
somebody you really don't even have to
say much more than that you're like what
if it was just
headphones just really well done and
everyone else will not or a thermostat
just a you can't argue with somebody who
is just saying we're just not going to
do it you know all the bad ways you
could do this we're not going to do any
of those just beautifully done and Nest
is a thermostat that's just it's just
beautifully done this is a air qu air
quality monitor that is beautifully done
so go to birdie. design and you'll see
it it's this white circle with a small
yellow bird like the Twitter old Twitter
logo and when it's it's like uh when
it's pointed up like a cuckoo clock that
means the quality is good if the air
quality in your house ever drops rather
than you know beeping like an annoying
smoke alarm or having tons of numbers
and and strange colors and you're like
oh God you get stressed out the bird
just changes positions just to tell that
hey the air quality is not great right
now and then you look in your app and
it'll tell you all about it so this
thing is awesome I think it's big in
Europe it's not actually they're like
just now like actually I don't know if
this is true but they're expanding to
the to the States now I think it's
bigger in Europe I think this is a
fantastic idea beautiful website the
tury is DKK what's DKK um some type of
Monopoly money I don't know yeah Danish
Crone ah the croner yes how can I
forget so yeah this thing cost 2,000
DKK an unknown amount of dollars um $300
$300 that's 300 it's beautiful it's a
piece of art it's wonderful so we talked
about this with Steph Smith Steph Smith
said that these air quality control like
monitors they're gonna she she said
they're going to explode she and then
she went on and said uh uh she goes I
predict that the subreddit called air
quality is going to be the next big
thing it only has 4,000 Subs but it's
been doubling every 6 months and I think
that um with wildfires and all this
other stuff that air quality control is
going to become a huge thing and I keep
seeing people tweet this constantly they
have these little digital meters and I
don't know what the measurement is but
they say CO2 is this number and it looks
like a little digital clock and they're
everywhere man people are traveling with
them I'm seeing this everywhere now that
she told us about this yes exactly so
she was saying like you know she's like
I noticed that sleep r/ sleep quality
went through this crazy Trend over the
last you know four years where sleep
became like you know the Vogue kind of
Health Trend and um she's like I think
air quality is going to be next look at
the growth of the of the air quality
subreddit the products on Amazon that
are there and it's kind of like an
immature space and I think this is a
wonderful beautiful product design for a
product that's that's in that space yeah
I mean I'm looking at the Amazon ratings
right now I mean some of these products
have tens of thousands of reviews um
this is going to be a thing man this is
going to be like the next version of
ring I think uh these air quality
controls but the thing about it is I
don't know if this is pseudo science
like like I don't know the truth of is
are you willing to bet your life on it
that's that's the beauty of these
products right that's the beauty is it's
like a dog vitamin it's like I don't
[__] know if this works like but like
I'll buy that insurance like right but
don't you love your dog yeah how do I
get Co2 out of my house I could tell you
I don't breathe less I I don't know
remove the car from the living room I
don't know how to do it it's coming from
me I think
like yeah I don't I don't know how to do
it but when I see it I'm like that
sounds important it's like the word
leaky gut or a juice cleanse like well
if you use those words I guess I have to
do it right I don't know if I have leaky
gut but as sure as hell am willing to
like take any product I will stop it you
know just in case um all right I've got
one more quick thing yeah you go I need
some
device so I own a Facebook group you
know one of my hobbies is I have
Facebook groups I'm one of the only
people that that actually do that I
actually have three or four I've got a
couple that are in the 60 and 70,000
range but I have one that when Trend
shut down I just posted in there and I
said um I don't know what I'm going to
do with this but here's a Facebook group
I call it uh I actually am not going to
say the name of it because I don't want
to get flooded with new people joining
and I just said uh this Facebook group
is going to close down I just made a new
one you guys can all hang out in there
it's got 3,000 members most of them are
people who have small businesses doing
hundreds of thousands of dollars it's
mostly like those types that that size
of business I have no intention to
monetize it but I wouldn't be lying if
in the back of my head I'm just thinking
this could be something I'm missing out
here the group has a lot of um traction
people post every single day are you a
member of it uh I think what did you
call it uh let's let's give it a you
wantan to give it a plug or you don't
want to give it a plug it's
called yeah terrible name I think it's a
hilarious name and it's in the tagline
is shipping products with the Bold fast
fund energy it's a community of people
who build and talk business that are
bold Fast Fun the artists formerly known
as Trends we're a pirate ship of people
who care about talking nerdy business
stuff showing out projects asking
questions and commiserating with their
fellow Pirates and mostly because Trends
kicked us out and we're a bunch of
degens we need a place to go to uh and
so I created this group it's got 3,000
members dozens of posts per day if I
wanted to monetize this which I I
actually am not sure I will because I
don't want to work on it what would you
do the real answer is kind of a boring
answer I would absolutely not bother
monetizing this I'm not going to there's
a 1% chance tell some reason why you
have a incredible business that you
already you know own and can focus on
any ounce and of Mind share and time
share that you spend on not that
business on some really secondary
business is dumb and wasted I agree I
agree that's the first thing but but we
are a podcast where we talk about stuff
right right right yeah so for for the
sake of argument I'll tell you what you
could do so I do think you probably
should have called it something like the
artist fil really known as Trends I
think that's like a better uh better
name I think you could simply reboot
Trends that's the first simple obvious
idea right so uh let's not let's not you
know over complicate things people liked
Trends these are people that already
were in Trends and paying customers of
Trends transend is now free slash
like you know different let's just say
so there's an opportunity to do this I
actually think this is true about many
businesses there is this window like I
don't know three years after a company's
been acquired where you can literally
just start the same company again this
uh this is so common I see this all the
time people can literally build the same
company and the guy we sold the milk
road to he did the same thing he built a
company sold it for 45
and then he built the same company sold
it again to 4 for another $45 million to
the same company and then finally they
were like hey um non-compete this time
like you can't do this again to us and
um people really really underestimate
how much you could do this especially a
few years after a company's been AC a
product's been acquired because by that
time the team has changed the products
been folded in you know like a whole
bunch of stuff has gone a so I think
that's the easiest thing you could do I
believe they shut down Trends because I
think it had 500,000 people on the list
on the email list and HubSpot was like
dude like Trends charges $300 a year it
probably makes I don't know what it made
but let's say five or six million a year
um and we have 400,000 people saying
they're interested but haven't bought it
yet we can make way more money just
making it free and a portion of them
will buy our software and so but like
many entrepreneurs would be like yeah
but five million or $6 million a year
with two people running it that's pretty
dope I would like that as well the next
thing uh is I think you could use it for
growing Hampton so uh the way that y
commentator uses Hacker News so Paul
Graham basically creates Hacker News
Hacker News becomes the most popular
Forum or message board for developers
and um you know he could have been like
guys we got to do a job board and then
we gotta like you know do sponsored post
then we got to make a paid tier that
paid tier is going to have certain
permissions he's like no no no I already
have one of the best business models in
the world where YC can basically invest
in young hackers for like you know at
that time they were giving you like
$188,000 for 6% of your company or
something like that um all he needed to
do was just keep the thing free and keep
it awesome so that it became just like a
um an asset a marketing asset out there
for YC that existed for YC and I think
that that was the right move and that's
what I would if I was you for
Hampton you've given me ideas so look
here's how I think about some of these
small projects I think I don't want to
spend a second doing it but what I love
about little projects like this is
there's people in my family there's
people who I'm friends with I'm like I
don't want to spend a second doing this
but I will give this to you as long as
you keep it awesome and it makes a
little bit of money for yourself you
could just pay yourself with all that
money I don't care but as long as this
thing lives and it's great I don't need
to make a scent from it I think what I
can do is make this um a thing where the
community stays amazing and once or
twice a month I can have a sponsor that
pays a small enough salary for the
person running it to make uh to make a
living while keeping the community great
that's a great idea I'm glad I brought
this up I should do this I love how you
were like you gave me a great idea but
the thing you said was completely
different than what I said that's how
that's how this works that's how this
thing
works that's a little yes and there for
you to all my thespians out there Sam
just yes anded with a huge leap didn't
you say sponsored yeah yeah I said the
word sponsored oh you talking about job
post on Hacker News that's why I one to
the other saying what pul gram didn't do
and then you go that's what I you
stopped listening and then you said
sponsorships that's a great
idea for the record I'm not going to I'm
not going to spend any more than 10
minutes a month on this thing I'm not
actually going to do anything but it is
fun this is the point of the podcast is
to think about this stuff we'll see what
happens but I'm not personally going to
spend a second with this but you know
what I mean all these young Bloods that
we have in our crew who I would love to
work with in some capacity and I don't
have an option to work with them or
something I'm just thinking about it uh
I'm
just I'm gonna start doing yes say like
to my wife that says like hey let's go
do this yeah let's do that and we're
going to do it differently than what you
said we're going to do what I said
instead yes sand is my new thing yeah
that's a great idea and also at that
time we're GNA do this other thing like
what do you got to eat for dinner and
I'm like well I had Tai for lunch so not
that you're like Ty that's a great idea
I'm so glad you said
Ty that is so [__] funny I'm going to
yet sand the [__] out of people from now
on um well the beautiful thing about yes
anding people is uh instead of they
can't like argue with you because you're
like oh are you trying to be a buzz kill
and not yes and here are you trying to
like stop our flow they're like oh I
guess I got to go with this it's not
going the direction I want but
guess uh last thing you have Camp MFM
coming up on Wednesday I had to bow out
because I'm committed to this whole this
whole being a parent thing you know
whatever that thing is
the whole this whole you know being a
person dad and all that nonsense I'm
committed to it I saw the flyer you made
for it and I I did not have any fomo
until I saw that the Airbnb founder is
going in particular the Airbnb founder
who interviewed me for my job at Airbnb
and then fired me four days later one
day before I was supposed to start he's
going and I would have loved to have
gone to see that guy he uh by the way he
fired me for just cause he was right I
was wrong why um how did you get him Ben
Ben is the easy answer so we we went
into Camp MFM this year with a a fresh
mindset new year new US Camp MFM is
basically Sean and Ben you went and
found last year or we did two years ago
15 people including Mr Beast maybe 20
people you last year we went to a kind
of a crummy house that was just huge and
you somehow got us all Nikes and then we
went like basketball shoes and then we
went and like played B verion of the
story sucks here's what happened last
year let me just yes angre real quick
so so yes but completely
different last year um Ben was like why
don't you host an event why don't you
host like a conference or something like
that there's so many people that you
know are in the kind of podcast audience
Twitter audience that would love to come
I said yes but a couple of problems a I
don't really like big groups of people
like I really have a bad time when I go
to events with like a lot of people in
them it's just socially not something I
enjoy second conferences are kind of
boring and if I don't want to like if I
when I hear oh you're invited to come to
a conference either you're gonna watch
people talk or you're G to get to talk
on stage it's not uh again I have that
Spencer Scott urge to just do something
different with my life so I said why
don't we do something different I said
what would I what would be the instead
of just saying no let me instead ask
what would be the event that I would
love to go to I'd be looking forward to
and I was like oh what I would want is
just kind of like a summer camp for
adults um where it's kind of like a
summer camp like I used to go in the
Summers to play at a basketball camp so
I love basketball I would just go to
something that's super fun we're gonna
play and then we hang out and we talk
yeah we do that after but like the main
thing is we're gonna play and we're
gonna compete and we're gonna have a lot
of fun um and that all the guests you
know it's a small number of guests but
that all of them are like the 20 Most
Fascinating People I know which we tried
it last year it was amazing um Mr Beast
I tweeted out the thing I said here's my
my dream for an event and I had three
bullet points and I put out a Google
form and in that Google form there was
like 200 people replied of which 199 we
did not invite to the event but one of
them was Mr Beast and I didn't know he
followed us I thought it was a prank
when I was like oh yeah sure your
Twitter handles Mr Beast yeah sure
whatever and then his email was like a
real name but it was kind of like a like
a Yahoo or something like that I was
like ah this got to be fake then I get a
d so I don't even reply the next day he
DMS me says so are we doing this or what
and I like you know spit out my drink
and I was like oh [__] oh okay yeah yeah
we're doing this uh where do you live oh
North Carolina funny coincidence we're
doing it there and so I was like I'm GNA
make this easy for him and we just so
happen to be doing it in Greenville
North Carolina yeah exactly and so we we
went you were there it was a great time
there's 27 people and we we invited this
uh guy who trains a bunch of NBA stars
like Kyrie Irving and Trey young and
these guy he TR used to train Kobe and
he came down he basically was like kind
of the our our coach and it was a bunch
of out of shape you know business people
plus a couple of entertainers so like
you know um people from the the
entertainment world that that joined as
well anyways it was a good time so this
year we wanted to do it again but we
made you know came up with some
differences so I was like even less
people last year we had 27 people this
year we cut it down to I think 177 um
which was we really only tried to have
15 but we ended up at 17 we we said well
we don't want to do it with the same
exact group every single year because
again the point of this is we're trying
to rotate kind of like you know just
people we want to use it as an excuse to
meet people we want to meet and by the
way you forgot we all lived or it was
only two nights but we all stayed in the
same air it was just a huge house it was
like a family's house that had all their
like like I I shared a I shared a I
shared a bunk bed with Ramon in the Sun
and uh and then they had like a lake
that we were swimming in it was awesome
it was a crappy like inside house but
that's actually made it amazing it made
it really fun well it was the best house
in Raleigh North Carolina but that says
more about Raleigh North Carolina than
it is the house so so it was uh but so
this year we were like all right we're
doing it again and um we came up with
kind of a dream guest list now why did I
say that Ben was the way that we got uh
the co Airbnb guy to come because Ben
somehow just like he is the Twitter API
like he just consumes so much content
that he know I was like you know it's
like a AI search I was like who is a
super interesting business person who
also loves to play basketball he's like
oh I think the Airbnb guy plays
basketball every weekend and I was like
how could you possibly know that well
and he owns the San Antonio Spurs own
San Antonio Spurs and I was like oh wow
so uh we reach out to Joe uh Joe's ass
he finds me his email I cold email him
and I say hey you don't know me from
from you don't you don't know my name's
Sean but you don't know me from John you
know here's the here's this event that
we're doing I think you would really
like it um yeah we'd love to have you
and he calls me and he's like basically
calls me ask me some questions but I
could tell it's just like are you in are
you like an insane person like do I want
to be around you for two days or not and
um and so he's coming there's a the
guest list is kind of amazing so I'm gon
to do a recap of it afterwards but what
a what a thing to manifest uh like you
know Jess ma came on the podcast she
said this thing she I was like so you
you run a a venture Studio an idea lab
like what do you call it she's like oh
no I don't call it anything she's like I
have a team of people that are like my
little manifestation company like if I
want to make something happen they just
help me make it happen make it come make
it go from idea to a thing and uh now
that's how I think about what me and Ben
do it's not like a holding Co it's like
a manifestation Co it's what is the life
we want to have and then we just sort of
make it so and this is one thing that
you know I would want to have as my kind
of like annual annual thing that I do
yeah I gotta tell you so this I'm flying
out tomorrow right so I'm like all right
I got to get my my haircut and my beard
Tri I gotta get I gotta get fresh by the
way your haircut looks quite good you
should do that more often you'll notice
my hair might look good but my beard
looks untouched why is that what
happened let me tell you a little story
so this is a little I I didn't think
that well I think that and so I uh I go
to this Barber Shop normally I have this
guy who comes to my house cuts my hair
and it's like a routine so I don't need
to think about it but he couldn't come
so I was like all right I'm g go to this
place I go and uh this I'm like great
yeah I got this big event just need a
you know little standard F booy haircut
trim the beard a little bit and uh we're
good right he's like I don't do beards
and I was like pretty sure I booked that
what do you mean um he's like I was like
this is a barber shop right like what
else do you do if not hair and beards
he's like he's like I just don't want to
mess it up I was like well I also don't
want you to mess it up but I needed all
right whatever weird but okay and then
he's like okay what do you want for your
haircut I show him a picture and he
starts doing it and um super nice guy
but I noticed that his hand is like
really trembling while he's cutting my
hair and I'm like okay this is
interesting um I feel bad for him but
you know Sam I also feel bad for me
because you don't want to get your
haircut by somebody whose hand is
trembling with clippers so I'm like okay
this is now a high-risk situation I'm
about to go to my biggest event of the
year I hired this vlogger to follow me
around not try to have an effed up
haircut but I put I put my faith in this
guy we did it the haircut turned out
okay I was like you know what beard
forget I ever said it not doing it um
and he's like he at the end he goes
thank you so much you were You' have
been so kind to me and I go I didn't do
anything what do you mean I just sat
here got my haircut he's like I was so
nervous I have never done that haircut
and I was like hey man what the hell
what why are you telling me this
afterwards you got the most basic
haircut that every guy ever has like
this is the standard guy haircut what do
you mean this is a barber shop you work
here right like did I just ask a
customer to cut my hair most bizarre
experience he's like I was so nervous
he's like I've done one of these before
and I totally screwed it up Bianca she's
amazing he points at he points to this
woman Bianca goes she had to fix it for
me she's so good with the Clippers I'm
like then why did Bianca cut my hair
what's happening right now you should if
he wants you should tell him you should
start a trash company fit right in dude
not racist experience am I right I was
laughing so hard I was like what just
happened to me this is like a comedy
skit it's GNA be Wednesday to Friday I'm
this is the I just got fomo for the
first time last night when I saw uh that
Joe was gonna be there I'm I'm bummed I
can't go hopefully you you uh do good
and hopefully you get some good podcast
yeah that's a lot of pressure I'm just G
to try to have a good time uh that's my
goal no or make videos
Bing all right that's the
[Music]
pod